my name is nari sol i'm a pianist
composer and recently i helped my mom
who is not a composer not a musician
write her very first piece of music i
did this because i find the act of
creating something original especially
music to be very therapeutic it can help
us get through some very dark and
difficult times
and recently
my mom's mother my grandmother
passed away and everybody was going
through a rough period i wanted to help
my mom process and express some of her
emotions by creating a piece of music in
memory of her mother and this is a
little bit about how we put all of this
together so the very first step was
actually to bring this idea up to my mom
and see if she would be up for the
challenge
so like i said she's not a musician and
this would be putting her way out of her
element and i also didn't want to burden
her with anything during this emotional
period but she said yes because she
loved the idea of doing something for my
grandmother and also i just assured her
that if she wants to stop at any time
she's free to do so the second step
involved just gathering as many memories
about my grandmother as we could in
order to help us brainstorm how we
instead of doing something somber she
wanted to write a piece of music that my
grandmother would have enjoyed and loved
it
so my grandma was a very joyful person
she really loved music she loved to sing
and dance she was always cracking jokes
and smiling and she made everybody
around her feel warm
um
[Music]
then i took my mom to the piano and my
first attempt at getting her started
kind of flopped
so i was just asking her if she can
think of a part of a melody or a
particular rhythm
if she liked a certain range in the
piano and all of this was way too vague
and i can tell my mom was losing a
little bit of confidence and she was
just lost
kromeon
so sure enough that evening my mom told
me that i should just write something on
my own that she didn't feel comfortable
composing but i wanted her to try one
more time because i felt that the way i
introduced this idea to her at the piano
was a bit flawed
the next day i took her outside with a
small keyboard already this is less
intimidating and i had some structure
i'll give you four pitches
[Music]
d
f
g
b flat
so i chose the pentatonic scale because
my grandmother was a huge fan of korean
trot music or trotsu and this sound is
present in most of the
so the major pentatonic scale has five
pitches
but i gave my mom four of those five
just to make it easier less intimidating
and
i made the first note that she would
naturally play
not the root because i find that if you
are overly focusing on the root note for
a melody it becomes a little square so
that's just a little adjustment i made
but i think it made a huge difference
[Music]
by giving her a solid framework and less
options to work with she seemed to come
up with ideas with more confidence and
ease
[Music]
wow
[Laughter]
foreign
once my mom finished her melody i
started to think of ways that i could
produce this for her
the key point here was to try to
incorporate as many things my
grandmother loved into the music the
music boxes
so this part of the process was very
meaningful for me because i was able to
sit down and remember so many little
details about my grandmother and
the way she appreciated music even
though we actually never talked about
music i knew that she appreciated the
sound of the piano many different
instruments
[Music]
in
[Music]
[Music]
while choosing the sounds and
instruments to put into the music
it was more about
remembering and imagining what she would
really enjoy rather than choosing things
that maybe sound better or i think sound
better
and this was very very special and it
gave me a chance to
feel close to her again with music
next i had my mom learn and practice her
music since i wanted her to actually
perform it herself i knew she could do
it even though we had a very limited
amount of preparation time and it was
also a great opportunity for her to go
back and review her music
she can change certain things she
actually changed her mind about the
rhythm in a few parts and about the
tempo
[Music]
you were
[Music]
and now we present to you pink pizzarang
or pink love
amma
oh
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
thank you for watching
if you haven't already please consider
subscribing to watch more videos about
the creative and technical sides of
making music and a very special thank
you to my patrons on patreon for making
these videos possible